F
U.S. IS SHOWINEA
THATHE WOR OF OMICRON D
SOON BSEWHHIOPPED 8% FROM A
FOLLOWEDEEDEAN LASE IN CASES
INANSB
D  EXPLAINS WHAT'S SIDE OF OCR
SURGE. EVEN INHE
OMICROE WAS IN THIS WARD
PATIENTS.RUSH TGA.E NEVER STOPPE
SURGERY.
WE NEVER CLOD OUR COFFEE
TOITORCO
HE Heporter: THIS AFTER THREBRU.
44 80% OO D S ARITIES IL
PATIENTS.
>> Reporter: BUT WHEN THE HI
VERSION OF COV WAVES OFF IN UTRO
OMICRES NEXT?BALLY, WE'VE REAL.
AND BY THAI MEG TO
W THAT SOETN UNCTIO
NORMAL.
>> Repor IN SUWETTA, THEY T FUHE
THRIVING.
STILE.eporter:CI 'M
E THAT THE HIGVELS OF
IOANNTIAL
ADULTS ARED, ATES AROUND 40% OF
SIGNIFICANTLY SOFTENED OMICR'SI
DEADLY.
FTHIS YEAR?
PR RINS GOIN BER NOW.
ISTIC ABOUT WHWE
ARE RIGHT NOT'S
THAT WE CAN POY EMPLATE,UTN OTH
>> IT JUSTS WILE.Y ARE ING TO L
'T CAUSE
AS SEVER
IN A B SETTING,
OM
AGAINST THE  VIRULENA HE I
D
>> THERE AD CE E FROM NOSCU THII
STANDING HERE AND DISCUSSING T.
AND MAYBE THVI
SURPSES AGAI
MINION,NOW THAN W. AS TIME, WE.
>> Reporter: SCIENTISTS JUKNOWN
D-ND GAME.
T MANYO HE IS NDS,
NTN O YEARS
TE THIS  JAKE.
I N'
I'VE SN WITH THESEIGHT NOW.
BUT T IT IMPOSSIBLE TO
ATN WILL HAPN
THEY DO Y,UGT IT'S GET THO BOOS
SHOTTOM
JAKE?
RG, SOUTTE IT.ZIE IN
>>> EARL
ONI SAID HHOS VADREN U
WIE AVAILABLE PERHAP
A MONTFR NTHERE ARE NEARLY 20 M
NTRY UNDER THE
AGE OF
MANY OEIR PARE
RENEL OFERHEEA.
NPR,E GIVERS OF
G CHILDREN SAY HOCK BOTTOM.
"NEW YORME RE
R 5 STUCK IN LIMBO
CNN, P OKIDS ARE NOTNOW. NOWO S
ANDREA CLICA AND I CAN
GEE  AAS
.THS USELESFIVE DAYS AFTER S IF
THEIR FAMILYITUATION>> IT'D BEC
SOMEONE THAT CAN'T B
PARENTS THAT I'M WITH  THE
TELL THEM YOU NOT
ER IN USIN
VOIC IN SP OUT, IN
ASKING FOROM OTH
PARENTS ANOTR PELEBUI THINK WE
>> WHA DO YOU HAVE FORTHE N SU?
>> YEAH.
THE FIRST STEP RREME TS FINITE.
ITMSE  NECSE EEN SO LONG AND
MOVING GOAS D
UNCERTAINTY E INCREDIBLY
ARE MUCH CLOSE
CHILDREN GTINGTH
PEOPLEOPHEERD NEWS  WE HOPETHE
MUCH DIFFERENSIN
OKAR
D THE RS
TWO
PEOPLE YOU RELIED ON AND MAD
YOU LAUGH D GAVE YOU A E
N
WRITEE WROTE UNPREDICTABILITYF
LER. ORR THE
THXT ALERT WILL COME.
WE C UNPREDICTABILITY?
NK THERE N TO BE ORE ACTION
SUI DONK THAT PARES O  MORE BECE
D.OF COMMUNITY ISOFERING THELPH
RETURN.
'SGET US THROUGH.
F BAL
SICK THEMATELYGSGUILT ANAME,
SE BLAME IATTION
SHOWING THE LU TOF
CHILD.
THE CHILD NEEDS LOVELYE THT INFU
OVER.HROUGHY ANEN KS CO
THIS EMBETHE
M FEEL I
TIME ANDF  FT SAFER AND EVEN IE